This episode of Your Mom's house is brought to you by Saatva luxury mattress.
The only online mattress company that provides free delivery set up and mattress
removal.
[inaudible].
All right.
It's rolling.
We're rolling gene.
Okay Dokey mommies.
There's a lot to get into.
Big guests coming in today guys.
Exciting Times.
So much to cover.
Um,
you ready to do this?
And if I can say yeah.
Alright.
Alright,
let's go bro.
Wow,
that's me.
Your host scanning Qur'an holds.
Welcome to stripper reviews because here I am all alone with my hand Jang off
the old playboys because they're easier on my eyes and this smart phone.
Well,
welcome to your mom's house.
A snap.
It's so dynamic that he really is.
Forget how explosive he's guys a review and strippers.
It's always the cool guys.
The hot guys,
the guys worthy of strippers that love reviewing women was there.
What is making demands,
you know,
I don't even know.
Oh,
we're going to talk about strippers.
K One time,
salt up a Swedish Filipina named Brittany.
And uh,
it was pretty fun.
She was pretty game.
You touch her ass and her titties as much as she went on during the dance and
she didn't let me go downtown.
That was a,
I don't care.
Ass and titties.
I mean for $20 a dance at the time.
Yeah.
That is their job,
isn't it?
To let you touch them in some places I guess.
I mean in acts one $8 to,
it's like 40 easy way,
which was what it was.
It's not anymore.
33rd Taiwan,
they 40 with top law used to be $20 from top off.
Oh Gee.
Wow.
How'd it made her action with an Ethiopian stripper name of Alisay
dry sex is fun.
Contacts
wrong with this person.
Hold on.
All right.
Sorry.
I just wanted to make sure that we were recording the correct Chicco watts.
Well,
you want to hear everything that this guy has to say.
I mean,
I just got the Alice a review.
Let's see what else he's got.
No,
she dropped down to her
knees,
you times and play with my dick through my shorts.
You're wearing shorts to the Strip club and I'm wearing basketball shorts to the
strip club.
It was fine.
You know,
I think she likes my deck.
You,
I had a decent job on it wasn't,
you know,
the best I've ever had and I'm pretty proud of the width of my penis when it's
fully gorge.
First of all,
can we just celebrate happening memory and his ability to recollect every detail
of the girls.
Look her name,
what she remembers when we back when it was $20.
Now it's $40.
Yeah.
He knows what Al is a was her ethnic background.
That's fantastic.
It is.
I think it's a mark of youth.
They say you remember lots of details when you're young and then by our age it's
just gone.
Right.
A game board partner if you were playing,
you know,
board games.
True.
Yeah.
Um,
a really good thing is,
uh,
well we've got all the marks of a great home video number one,
the background,
he's in the bathroom,
so there was a shower curtain audio.
There's a weird humming sound in the background.
It's hard to,
it's got an impressive shower.
If we're going to be honest,
it's not flattering.
This is like,
you know,
it's,
it's a in your twenties it's just what it is.
Yeah.
I think isn't a 20 it looks,
it doesn't look so young,
but he's youthful.
But he's one of those guys that went bald at 18 you know those unfortunate
souls.
I feel so bad for them.
You should do what I'm doing.
I can't believe he's not going all the way.
Same length.
Sure.
He's actually letting the horse shoe kind of grow out and in your twenties that
is n sanity to look at it.
I hate when it happens for guys that early.
It's so sad.
It's not fair.
Life is cruel.
It's got a bad beard,
mustache game to talk shit cause it's trimming the mustache down or it's not
growing in very beard.
Painful or somewhat full.
Yeah.
I don't.
So can I ask you as a guy,
$1 million makeover.
Yeah.
We what,
what compels a young man to make reviews like this.
Like he probably knows on some level it's not a good idea.
Right.
You know,
he's probably,
he knows it's mean spirited.
The way we're critiquing his looks.
Yeah.
I don't think he thinks it's mean spirited.
It's,
it's,
you're so oversexed and you so want sex,
but you figured talking about sex,
some part of your mind goes,
if you put it out there,
it might lead to,
that's really what your brain's doing.
It's the secret.
It's like if I build it,
they will.
He just wants,
he wants sex and this is just the best they can do right now.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
Until he finds his own pair of jeans and then you can fart 33,600 times.
That's exactly what I've done.
And 14 I had some far too yesterday.
Yeah.
Well you did the night before.
Well here's what your Apricot,
oh my God,
I'm so stupid because I was constipated and I got these hemorrhoids leftover
from pregnancy and I started eating dried apricots cause that usually does the
job right quick.
Yeah.
And I ate a bunch of them and it was rancid.
It smells like sulfur cause there's so much bad in the apricot's.
Right?
Yeah.
Holy Cow.
Well,
what caused your farts?
I don't understand.
We all want the same thing that was on the rip tickle.
You ripped it care for that.
That cardio,
yeah.
Gets your,
your system going.
And the thing is,
I had some sneaky like,
Eh,
kind of park and I was like,
yeah,
this sucks.
You know?
And then as I was going,
going,
I had like a big burst to come out.
Uh,
it was nearly sexual in nature.
Feels good,
Huh?
It didn't smell good,
but it felt good.
Can I tell you the dumbest thing I did though is that I ate those apricots and
then went to get a massage and I mean,
how stupid can you be?
Pretty stupid.
I was like,
what am I thinking?
And I had the whole,
I really,
I fell asleep on the table and then I had to like wake up quickly and really
clench my butt cheeks together because one was about to like really escaped.
Yeah.
So no,
it,
it's not good.
Was here and talking about his dick more.
Okay.
It's halfhearted.
A pretty good shot.
I don't know how to like serious chubs this year.
I'm looking out on my deck,
like that's a monster.
I got it.
I'm good.
And all I am
saying this on camera at all.
I asked,
he was master.
Yeah.
See he goes,
I'm saying this on camera.
He knows it's his mind telling them like,
why are you doing it?
Like I'll put this out there.
Yeah,
he knows you're still overwhelmed with horniness.
he knows he nasty.
It's,
it's um,
it's inhibiting his ability to actually restrain poor judgment.
That's how overwhelming that testosterone be.
The buildup of,
of all that pent up stuff.
And then he's like,
I'm just going to talk about coming and since I'm not telling you there's a,
there's a window in,
in men's life that it's just overwhelming.
What is that age like?
It starts,
it starts,
if it really,
I think you really peak out between 17 and 22.
Those are,
that's the window of like,
Oh
yeah.
That's where it's the most intense and that's,
And that's when you can get into the most trouble with and that's what usually
happens.
And that's your life guys.
Act The most recklessly and yeah.
Impulse control.
Oh my goodness.
Yes.
So I guess,
okay.
Yeah,
we should probably pass,
pause,
pause.
We'll keep this going here.
Okay.
All right.
We're back.
Yeah.
We had to do a quick pause because our esteemed guest has a role and we're
excited.
So you guys were on already ready.
You're all,
yeah,
yeah.
But just for a few minutes.
Okay.
You did the intro.
We did the intro and we were talking about this cool guy.
Yeah.
And uh,
and uh,
your name is Tom.
Yes.
Tom Green.
Tom and Tom.
Yeah.
A proud
Canadian.
Hello?
Like me?
Yeah,
Canadian by Browser,
Ontario.
How long did you,
do you grow up there now?
Man,
I moved to California when I was like three.
I thought I knew that.
Yeah.
What part are you from?
I am from Ottawa.
I just think about that for a second.
It's a capital B capital.
Very good.
Yeah.
That's nice.
I'm one of those Americans that knows things.
Yeah.
Because you're married to a Canadian.
That's right.
Nobody else would know that auto was the capital.
Yeah.
No,
I know that I is,
is really nice.
Like I hear it's the,
it's the Beverly Hills of Canada,
right?
Yeah.
Uh,
it's,
it's more like the,
uh,
the Laughlin,
Nevada of Canada.
It's very fitting for me.
It's,
it's kind of like a casino town.
Sure.
I will have three real estate.
Yeah.
I have two.
Uh,
I can,
I cannot tell a lie though.
I've never been to Windsor.
Okay.
I hear what I heard.
That's where people go to drink from Detroit.
Is there a surprise city in,
in let's say,
in terms of if you're traveling,
doing stand up that I'm like,
everybody knows,
you know,
we all hit Toronto,
Vancouver,
Montreal.
As you guys say,
Calgary,
Winnipeg,
Toronto.
What's the city that you're like,
you know what,
this is,
wouldn't normally be on your list,
but you should hit it.
Ottawa.
Really?
I'd say so.
Yeah.
Okay.
Cause it's the capital.
So there's lots of,
you know,
nice architecture,
lots of museums,
lots of,
it's a,
it's a million people.
So it's a
big,
small city.
Yeah.
That's more than,
you know,
it's,
it's not,
uh,
not like big,
like Toronto or Montreal or Vancouver,
but,
uh,
yeah,
it's,
it's a,
it's because it's the capital.
It's interesting.
Very beautiful city.
Go in the summer,
don't go in the winter.
Very cold.
Very cold city.
Yeah.
Um,
you know,
but,
uh,
you know,
other cities,
uh,
now,
I mean,
you pretty much named them all,
you know,
Calgary,
Edmonton,
Edmonton.
Yeah.
I'll probably,
you know,
at another city I've not been to in Canada,
which I am sort of wish I have had been there as Saint John's Newfoundland.
I have to stick.
That would be a very unique,
see,
that's what I'm looking for.
Yeah.
You get out there.
You're so almost like going to Ireland.
Okay.
I haven't been there,
but uh,
Prince Edward Island,
Charlotte town,
Prince Edward Island's kind of like that.
Okay.
The maritimes,
the East Coast Halifax.
Yeah.
Very.
You know what,
that,
um,
that summer winter thing reminds me of is when I first started touring and
working,
I started to go to Canada twice a year,
some in some places,
but I went every year to like those five,
six places.
And you know,
that second time you come through,
I guess you go in like February and you're like,
Hey,
fuck you,
my bad full house.
They're like,
yeah,
it's fucking 30 below out coming June.
Yeah.
Like you'll still,
you'll sell eight tickets.
And I'd be like,
Oh yeah,
they just the opposite of la because it drizzles everybody stays in
doors.
Yeah.
No,
but it's the example climates,
they all come out cause there and it's crazy.
Literally they have like six sold out shows and you're like,
wow,
like is everyone here to see me?
And they're like,
no,
they're all sold out all winter.
They just want to be inside.
They're looking for something to do.
Yeah.
Well it's,
uh,
it's,
it's kind of a bit of a catch 22 because it sucks being there in the winter
socks.
Yeah.
We're done.
That,
you know,
it's almost like more fun to go up and sell six tickets and be warm.
I know,
right.
It's so brutally cold for me.
Yeah.
You know,
it's funny to get in the argument like what's the coldest,
but I think the coldest week that I experienced on the road was in Winnipeg.
Yeah.
It was like January or something like that.
Was Un fucking believable.
It's so crazy.
I'll do Canadians.
I mean this is a question that I get asked,
but uh,
I'm curious to know from your American perspective.
Yeah.
Do Canadians laugh differently?
Is it a different reaction to the comedy?
I don't think so.
No.
Is it tempered slightly?
When we did that,
it was bonkers.
I feel like they're more down to have fun.
I used to always say this thing that I feel like is I still think holds true and
that is that I think smarter crowds in,
in smarter demographics get sarcasm.
And I find that for the most part that always translated in Canada,
which is that like you have your hard jokes and then you know like I would,
I do like tags that are,
that can be a throwaway line.
Sometimes those throwaway lines in certain places get like a 30% of the audience
and there's a lot of times that I would go to Canada.
I'm like 100% of the audience was with me on every throwaway line.
It's more like a Seattle type crowd.
Yeah.
Then a uh,
you know,
Huntsville,
Alabama toe
a little bit closer to scout.
I think so.
I mean I had great,
I did have one time now I remember the time that I did Calgary and it was like
15 minutes in and I was telling stories as you know,
the bit was like that that telling the story of what happened is the routine,
right?
Like I was on the flight and the Guy Duh Duh Duh Duh and like 10 minutes in this
guy goes,
are you going to tell a joke?
And I go,
these are jokes.
Like,
this is a story with jokes in it.
It was like,
man,
I'm about to see Henny Youngman.
Yeah,
yeah.
And I was like,
all right.
I remember specifically that that was a Calgary that's,
that's a,
that was probably just a,
that's just a weird rogue.
Yeah.
Occurrence I think.
I think so.
But I know I've had amazing,
the place I used to go twice a year for a while was the comedy mix in Vancouver.
Okay.
I grew up in there.
Really?
No,
it's a,
okay.
Well I think this was the old,
yes.
Okay.
And it's on Bernard Street at the Century Plaza Hotel downstairs.
Fucking tremendous.
Yeah.
I think that is the old Yuk calcs.
Giulia.
So it's really good.
But I know that Yucky Alex has that.
Uh,
they had that thing in Canada where they're like,
you play us and you don't fucking play anywhere else if you're starting out
there.
Yeah.
They really get upset.
Right.
I,
uh,
I started doing standup,
but y'all kicks when I was a teenager.
I read this about you,
that you started,
because
I remember them saying on Tom Green,
start doing standup.
I saw at the ice house and I was like,
that can't be right.
This guy has been funny for a million years.
And you started at 15,
it says,
yeah.
And at the same,
the same club,
the clubs move,
but it's the same owner.
Um,
uh,
Howard Wagman he's been there,
been there since we're over 30 years,
you know,
and a great guy.
And uh,
yeah,
but I mean,
I wasn't touring,
you know,
I didn't tour.
I was,
I started doing amateur night.
I'd go down when I was a kid because I wanted to see Harland Williams.
I love Harland,
Norm Macdonald.
I wanted to see those are like your heroes,
Jeremy Hotz.
They were,
I'll uh,
Canadians and they're all,
they were the headliners in Canada at the time.
Don't know how hot of a hand Jeremy Hotz has had in,
in standup,
especially in Canada.
I mean these,
these,
these guys were,
they were all in their twenties though then.
And they hadn't even moved to the states yet.
Harland and Norma had,
norm wasn't an on Saturday night live yet.
I remember when they all moved down here.
It was kind of like very inspiring because,
you know,
I was sort of a kid and I thought,
oh,
these guys were like 10 years older than me,
so I was sort of the,
the dream was,
wow,
they're going off to Edmonton tomorrow to do more standup.
Yeah.
Well I'm just stuck here in Ottawa.
There are going to the Yuk Yuks and the Edmonton tomorrow.
So it was amazing to think that you could just travel around doing standup,
you know?
Um,
but,
uh,
I,
I did it until I did it probably till I was about 20 and then I stopped and uh,
started,
uh,
I went back to school,
took a broadcasting and so eight started my show.
What is the time off between 20 and when you start it again?
How long?
Probably about 35.
I'm 59 years away.
Yeah.
I mean,
I don't think I ever really,
you know,
was,
yeah.
Basically for 15 years,
I was,
um,
I was doing a college radio show and then I started the Tom Green show and I
just did that all day,
every day.
You know,
that's all I did for 15 years was,
was basically worried about,
uh,
you know,
making weird videos and stuff.
Yeah.
Well I kinda like,
I kinda just,
uh,
I,
I definitely regret in some way,
not regret,
but sometimes I think in hindsight,
like,
man,
if I would have been nice to have been doing standup when my show was on him
TV,
that would have a good time to be there on the road.
But I told you this at the comedy store the other night.
I,
cause it's Kinda like we talked about that.
Yeah,
he did it because I,
it's,
it's kind of funny sometimes when you do this and you know,
you're working as a comic and then you see people in the green room where you're
like,
Holy Shit.
And it is Kinda funny man to me that,
you know,
your show.
I,
I think a lot of people may be experienced that a lot of people,
but some people experience having a show or you know,
working on a show and you're like,
I was on TV,
but your show was the first of its kind.
It was,
it's been,
you see a lot of bad imitation,
some goat imitations of you and what you did.
Like you're a true original.
And that was a must see television for us.
I don't know.
I mean I'm sure you read,
you realize it,
but like for me,
I mean what I was,
I think we figured out that I was probably 18 or 19.
Oh yeah.
Yeah.
Blew our fucking mind.
You our minds,
man.
Oh,
it was,
what was it at the peak of that being on MTV,
what was that experience like for you?
I mean,
it was a,
it was a sort of a surreal,
you know,
uh,
very surreal few years when just readjusting to that cause to that level of
fame.
Yeah.
Well,
cause you know,
I did the show,
like I said,
I was doing Yaki ox.
I say,
I don't even say I was doing stand up,
I was doing Yuk Yuks when I was 15.
You know,
I was doing,
I wasn't doing that as a kid.
And then I,
I what actually happened,
I got this record deal in Canada for a rap group that I was in when I was 19.
And that's kind of why I stopped doing the standup cause we went and we started
this rap,
well,
I'd been doing it,
we go with your group calls,
we're called Oregonized rhyme and we got nominated for a Juno award in Canada,
which is like a Canadian grammy.
And we had,
we had a hit record but you know,
hit record in Canada.
Like,
you know,
we didn't make any money or anything like that.
It was just kind of like,
it was number one on the top 10 at 10 on the radio.
But you know,
we weren't selling records or anything like that.
And um,
and then,
um,
you know,
that kind of fizzled out.
I went back to school and uh,
and started the show with my friends from college,
from broadcasting school and did the show for about five years.
And you're just doing this for funnel and terribly volunteered a public access
station,
making videos,
making videos and it's hard.
It's all,
by the way,
this is like editing on avid machine.
They didn't have,
no,
not even that.
It was actually tape.
So you were,
it was tape to tape Beta cam or three quarter inch tape or high eight tape.
So you'd have two machines.
I edited everything myself so that's why I went to broadcasting school cause I
figured no one was ever going to make my show
no expectations while you're doing this like that it would
ah no,
I was,
I was kind of a very motivated and driven kid so I was actually,
I did have expectations.
I was trying to sell the show from the day.
Uh,
but you know like where you getting feedback?
Like were people coming up to you?
I was like,
uh,
like a total nerd,
like video geek.
And I mean,
the way I got the record deal was because I started buying a lot of like,
like I work a summer job and buy a drum machine and then I'd make this rap demo.
Uh Huh.
And then I would go to like,
when a local Canadian rap group was performing,
I'd show up with my demo tape and like,
like hand it to the,
the,
the manager,
you know?
Yeah.
And it's not so,
so I sort of like kind of hustled a little bit,
you know,
cause I was scared shitless that I was going to have to like,
keep working at dairy queen or whatever else.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
So I was just terrified of having a,
here's a great motivator.
Marketing jobs.
I was working as a mover,
I was working as a landscaper,
I was doing tons of stuff like that,
so I was terrified.
So,
so,
uh,
you know,
but basically when the show got picked up by MTV,
it was kind of like,
you know,
10 years of like hustling around trying to make something happen and then all of
a sudden,
you know,
it,
it sort of exploded overnight on MTV,
which was shocking because,
you know,
we didn't,
we didn't have MTV in Canada,
so we had much music.
Yeah.
I sorta sorta the same thing,
but are you living still in k?
Like do you fly over to make it or so,
so I was living,
uh,
in Canada and uh,
and I sent,
I mean,
there's the,
the long short story is I went and did this talk show in Canada called the Mike
Bullard show.
It was the David Letterman of Canada.
And I would do these ridiculous stunts on the show by things that I'm not even
sure I want to repeat.
Like I showed up with a suitcase and a,
as I repeat,
it showed up with a suitcase handcuffed to me.
And then in the middle of interview I opened it and there was a dead raccoon in
it,
and it's rotting.
Oh.
And I started shaving it and then they have to stop tape and the host goes and
is sick,
you know,
and uh,
it's like,
makes like news and stuff in Canada.
It was a,
I should not be repeating this should,
uh,
I should not be turned on.
It's on,
it's on youtube.
But uh,
anyways,
so at that,
at one of those tapings,
uh,
I met,
um,
my future manager,
who's now my friend Howard Lapidus and he managed Dr drew and Adam Carolla.
Yeah.
And they were doing love line on MTV and he saw my crazy talk show appearance
and I give him some tapes and he took him to MTV and that's how I got an SUV.
Isn't that crazy?
Wow.
So we know what I love about your story is that you did that self hustle and an
era where it kind of wasn't as easy as it is now.
Like you hear kids complaining like,
how do,
why it's like,
Bro,
you've got this,
this is all you fucking need now.
You can make a TV show on this.
There's no excuse to
not do it now,
but to do it,
how to punk rock is it that you did it in a time where it was fucking so hard to
do and no money and no brain was sort of like saw,
like the,
you couldn't go buy a video camera because a video camera was $2,000.
And then if once you had a video camera,
what are you gonna do with that?
You can't edit the video.
How thought about where I went to college so I could get my hands on a video
camera.
He's how plant,
how planned out were bits.
Were these like just off the top of your head,
let's just do this sort of a mixture like,
uh,
so like,
we would spend a lot of our time writing,
you know,
we'd sit down,
me and my buddies and we think of what's the most ridiculous thing we can think
of to do and we'd,
you know,
plan things out.
And then we would also do a lot of just sort of wandering around the city with a
video camera,
talking to people.
Um,
so there's a mixture of things like the prank.
So my parents were planned out,
you know,
um,
but,
uh,
you know,
and there was lots of sort of performance already kind of stunts and things like
that.
But then sometimes stuff would just happen where like a guy would start yelling
at me on the street and that was like funnier than anything.
So,
you know,
so great parents.
I mean,
you were doing clubs at 15 and they seemed very unfazed by
your shell.
What was the attitude and in real life about all this stuff about you?
Uh,
well they were always very supportive.
I'm very supportive of everything,
but then the show got a little,
you know,
in their face,
and they were conflicted because,
uh,
you know,
the,
I was in college studying this stuff,
so he sort of saw that I was applying myself to my college by,
you know,
making videos.
But,
but,
uh,
we would,
we would go,
we would get them a lot in the middle of the night.
So they were less supportive cause it was three o'clock in the morning when we
were barging into their room or whatever.
But,
um,
yeah,
you know,
uh,
they,
they were,
they were supportive when I was a kid,
when I was,
uh,
you know,
when I was 16 years old,
we are 17 years old.
We had this opportunity to go record music in New York and they like paid for
are,
you know,
uh,
our trip down there and me and my buddy from my rap group and we went down to
New York,
Richard Music for the summer and you know,
I snuck into NBC and snuck into the Letterman studio and all sorts of stuff,
like really got kicked out.
But yeah.
What was,
um,
what did they think of like the explosion of the show?
You know,
I,
uh,
like they were like really happy when the show got picked up because they
figured that I was like gone,
you know,
and I looked cause MPV,
basically,
to answer your question,
familiar,
MTV basically saw the tapes.
So we sent them the tapes and,
uh,
they said,
do you have any more of these tapes?
You know,
I sent like my five favorite clips.
Right?
Yeah.
So do you have any more of these videos?
I said,
ah,
yeah,
I have about 1000 of these videos actually all on bay,
you know,
mastered on Beta Cam,
real professional at that time,
professional level,
you know.
And uh,
they said,
okay,
we want you to come pitch the show.
And they flew me down to La,
put me up in the Chateau Marmont.
Uh,
no,
the,
the Mondrian Hotel,
the Mondrian.
And then,
uh,
I had to go over and pitch the show to the MTV executives at the House of Blues
and on this big pitch session.
And,
uh,
then they picked it up and moved me.
And did the pitch go well?
It went,
it went pretty well.
I kinda was like,
um,
you know,
I was very naive,
a person I think to show business and,
uh,
you know,
I,
uh,
was very,
very confident,
I think,
much more confident than,
than I am now actually,
you know,
to be honest with you,
because I was naive to the fact that I probably should not be confident,
you know?
Right.
But,
uh,
at that time I did not know that.
Nobody had told me that yet.
So,
you know,
I went a funny,
they'll have that probably had to.
Yeah.
I mean,
and they're like this guy.
Yeah.
Saying I showed up with,
uh,
the,
the executive at MTV would kind of like,
uh,
sort of shepherded me in there,
into this pitch meeting had told me,
okay,
I want you to bring these four clips,
uh,
painting your parents' House,
plaid painting the car,
you know,
the slut mobile,
right.
Uh,
uh,
falling down on crutches on the street.
Uh,
I think go out of the one was when I went into a pharmacy to buy condoms and I
said,
oh,
I also want to play this one where I'm sucking milk out of cows that are dressed
as captain Kirk as amazing.
Yeah.
And they said no.
He said,
no,
don't,
don't play that one.
You,
you can't play that one sucking milk out of cows that are dressed as captain
Kirk.
Oh really?
No,
no,
don't play down.
So literally it's like,
you know,
this was pre digital,
so he tells me to make a VHS tape and there's gonna be a VHS machine and a walk
in the room,
pitch the show,
but the VHS and play them one at a time.
So I show up with a VHS tape.
I of course put the sucking milk cows that are dressed as captain Kirk is the
last video.
And so I also brought a suitcase again and Adidas bag actually.
And in it,
I had two bottles of shaving cream and a and a towel and basically went in,
pitched the show in front of all these executives,
talked about,
you know,
I,
I did have a serious pitch.
I remember,
I remember it was quite serious about like my understanding of what I was doing.
I mean I,
I did sort of explain to them,
you know,
we're shooting this in a home video camera,
people don't air stuff shot with a home video camera on television.
It's going to make it more relatable to kids who watch skateboard videos and
stuff.
And I explained,
you know,
sort of my theory behind it.
So they saw that I was somewhat rational person,
played all the videos,
big laughs,
big laughs in the room.
Then I played the last one told them that the executive told me not to play it,
played it covering his head.
It got a huge laugh.
People can like,
cause you know,
this was like,
this was before,
you know,
uh,
that gross out TV thing is going on.
You know,
it was before like,
you know,
Jack Ass and stuff like that obviously.
But there was some stuff like that.
I mean,
you know,
I mean there was like something about Mary,
I remember when I saw the movie something about Mary,
you know,
with uh,
the Kinda,
yeah,
yeah.
Um,
I was kinda like thinking,
wow,
that's pretty shocking,
you know,
so there was still some gross out stuff out there that was before the was on
MTV.
But uh,
but anyway,
so I had the,
the pitch and did and then I,
I for whatever reason thought this would be a good idea.
I went and I laid down on the board room table,
why I'm in front of all of the top executives at MTV,
pulled out these two cans of shaving cream and it's covered myself with shaving
cream completely my face and started thrashing around.
Like I used to like to thrash around a lot,
like very violently.
And after a pitch went well after the controlling,
well rushing round I streaming,
I want to be on MTV,
I want to be on MTV.
And then I got up and I some shaving cream off my face and I put a dollop of it
on the forehead of just the guy who looked like he was in charge.
I just,
the whole room was like,
I mean I was sensing the energy,
like I was getting laughs,
you know,
like everyone was dying,
they couldn't believe this was happening.
And I,
and,
and I did that lightly and it was Brian Graydon who was the head of the network
and then I left and got in the elevator and everybody was clapping and laughing
and they called me the next day and said,
yeah,
we're picking up 10 episodes.
You're moving to New York City.
We got you an apartment.
Uh,
you know,
your friends can come with you.
They've,
they brought two of my friends down who were,
you know,
working on the show with me.
She's got them apartments,
apartments,
nice employee,
very nice.
Midtown Manhattan,
right by MTV,
right around the corner.
It was pretty,
it was pretty crazy.
There's an excitement to getting an order,
obviously.
Yeah.
But like the way that it hit,
I don't think people now if they miss that that time.
Yeah,
that was definitely,
that kind of feels like that was pre Chappelle show.
It was pre internet.
Really?
Yeah.
That's what it is.
I mean there was,
there was internet,
but there was no video on the Internet.
Right.
So,
you know,
the new thing was people were now downloading music off Napster.
That was the only real access to content on the Internet.
Yeah.
You know,
like,
like audio or video content,
audio content.
But so the only place you could watch her music videos on much music,
the only place you could watch or I MTV much,
the only place you could watch.
So everybody watched MTV.
So it was,
it was while I remember it was like,
uh,
like the show basically had been on the air for a week and I don't know if you
remember like MTV,
the play like shows and blocks.
So I didn't know this was going to happen.
They had like five shows on the air.
He was like celebrity deathmatch Daria road rules.
You were on road rules.
Oh yeah,
I forgot.
I,
uh,
as I just
did some research.
Yeah.
That's cool.
Um,
I think you were a little more famous than me.
That's cool.
What's been interesting being on,
on road rules,
but,
Jeez.
But,
uh,
so there was,
there was not many shows and then they would run like my show like five times in
a row blocks.
So the show was on like 25 times a week,
30 times a week.
It was the impractical jokers of that time.
Yeah,
it was just all day,
all day.
I never really understood that or was expecting that kind of thing.
But all I know is the thing that was basically the thing that really freaked me
out was about,
I don't know,
two weeks after the show was on the air,
uh,
got call from Letterman wanted me as to be a guest on the show.
And uh,
then that fell through and I didn't get to go on the show as a guest,
but then I went on like a month later.
So it was like literally like six weeks into the,
into the,
to being,
living in our New York.
I was on who I idolized,
I guys,
Letterman.
I mean that was my whole,
my whole life was basically revolved around idolizing Letterman,
you know,
amazing to this of course was so
you can play videos here,
immobile.
So it's,
it's like there's,
there's slept mobile,
so I'm right.
So people can see this right now.
Yeah.
Obviously that would be,
but obviously if you're listening you can't see it.
That's true.
Yeah.
But this is on youtube so they can see it on youtube.
So this is like my parents' place when my house I grew up in,
uh,
I lived there,
at the time I was living there,
I'd move back into their house after college because I didn't have a job for
dads,
just editing videos all day.
Here's my dad going to work and this is work clothes and his trench coat,
he looks like inspector gadget or this briefcase.
And my dad was a military guy,
so he was pretty Canadian military.
You know,
we've got an army and he just starts walking down the street.
Yeah.
But you see,
you start to start to crack up here,
see,
see right around his this moment,
watch his face.
You'll see.
You sort of kind of realizes what are you going,
some effort had been put them right right here.
I think you'll see
to there there's,
yeah,
it's just,
it's a present.
He just doesn't,
it
quite nice believe
kind of brought it cost me $400 to get it done.
Cost $400.
So it was the most expensive.
We,
the amount of a bit we'd ever done cause we had to do it.
We bought,
the way we did it was we bought a 1992 Honda accord hood and we,
we painted
head in the middle of the night.
So it's 250 bucks for the hood and like a 150 bucks for the paint jewelry club
or something like that of that.
And then the middle of the night we just swapped it out,
filmed until they got really angry.
And then,
uh,
and then,
everything was fine.
We swapped it back and I still have the hood now to the status on my wall in my
garage.
Yeah.
Okay.
That's fantastic.
The whole way that Tom Green,
not Tom cigarette.
Yeah,
yeah.
No,
no,
not your personality is different.
He's like,
well anyway,
the point is you're so God damn likable,
Tom Green,
when you're doing horrible shit to people,
you have this gift of being somehow sweet and charming at the same time and
really rascally Oh,
I was just so fun to watch.
I feel like that's kind of like part of the,
like when I watch a lot of youtube pranks these days,
some of them go to the place where it's very mean.
And I feel like that's kind of were,
people don't quite understand.
Like that's where you lose the funding,
you know,
it's gotta be,
it's gotta be unjustified outrage.
Like when people get mad at you,
it's gotta be somewhat unjustified.
In this case,
it's justified,
but because they're my parents different,
it's different.
But if I did that to somebody else who weren't my parents and I didn't have that
relationship,
it would have been,
I would have been being mean by painting their car because they're my parents
and there's,
so there's sort of a,
a sort of a subtle line,
you kind of walk with it.
But my favorite part of this bid is like is like the next moment actually if you
play online,
because I did not,
this was not planned,
you know,
I figured he was going to get mad and we would,
that would be it.
But then he
right at this moment,
I realize all my dad's waiting at the bus stop now with all the neighbors.
So then I follow.
Right.
And so that ended,
this ends up being kind of like the funniest part of the bit.
Really just let me end,
let's talk to me to work so hard to make everybody get in that box all night
long.
My mom has no intention of talking to me.
It's pretty graphic too.
It's like there's not a lot left to the imagination
and it was,
let's look further ahead.
But anyway,
we'd go to the bus,
stop dropping
to our car,
Moody's video effects to
check where mom
is making me sick and I
gene,
it's love
those women on Love Dad,
Oh dad can take the bus to work.
I'm going to take the slut Moby over the
looking at all my neighbors.
It's
just
their faces,
first of all,
lesbians,
Lesbians and slots.
That's what I thought.
It would be a nice
whether or not it was funny or not.
I thought you liked that kind of thing.
What does that even mean?
That aside.
Now I know you don't like lesbians
don't want them on my car.
So it's not that you have a problem with lesbian stuff?
No,
no.
I have a younger brother yet.
And what,
what was he,
what's he like?
Uh,
he's uh,
he,
he's,
he's little bit more calm and reserved.
Was the aftermath of like camera's off the next time you see them after the
automobile.
So,
well,
the aftermath and were those the answering machine messages?
Those were coming in?
So basically what happened was we left the car park there and we didn't do
anything for awhile,
but I didn't,
we didn't reveal to them right away that we had the hood that we could switch.
You say a while a week?
No,
like,
like
eight hours.
Okay.
And My mother was leaving these answering machine messages.
You remember this,
this is also,
we didn't have cell phones then either.
Right?
Right,
right.
This is like literally primitive days.
So,
but she would call my landline that I had my own personal landline and leave a
voice message and I would listen to it.
I remember how the world worked then like you would kind of,
I mean memorize phone numbers.
That was how you stayed in touch with people.
Like if I left,
I knew my mother wanted to talk to me.
I didn't have a cell phone.
So I would go to a payphone,
put a quarter in it,
call my voicemail and check if my mother had called and left an angry message.
Sure enough she had and then a call 10 minutes later and she'd left another one
and another one.
And so as the day went on,
she left five and,
and I was sitting there,
you know,
with my friends who were sort of wrote the show together and we're thinking,
well we can't,
we can't go tell her that the hoods,
you know,
and then we can fix it right away until she stops leaving these awesome
messages.
Yeah.
Not too good.
So we just kind of waited and she was really mad because her,
her mother and her sister coming to visit that day.
So she was terrified that they were going to see this on the slap mobile,
you know,
so,
uh,
yeah.
Then sort of put her out of her misery at the end of the day and just went and
took the car up to the shop and swept the hood out and
eight hours making people freak.
I'd given within 20 minutes.
I'm just kidding.
I'm kidding.
Yeah,
it was,
it was kind of a,
yeah,
it was,
I kind of have this relationship with my parents were joking like that.
Like it was kind of a kind of acceptable,
I mean,
like they,
I could tell they thought it was,
they would watch the show every week,
so it would,
so the show aired live,
it was live on Thursday night on his public access station called Rogers Cable
and in Ottawa.
So every Thursday night I would run around all week and film these clips and
Thursday night I'd go sit in a studio and we go live and we sprayed the clips
back and I'd have it local guests on and things like that.
But,
um,
they would watch,
you know,
so,
and they would always kind of laugh at themselves afterwards,
but it was just sort of in the,
so we had to kind of up the ante a little bit every time.
Did your dad laugh eventually about that incident?
Oh yeah,
sure.
Yeah.
I mean they,
they,
they did.
And uh,
I mean it kind of,
it kind of,
uh,
so the,
the,
we went to New York and they thought the pranks were done and that we had this
prop budget now from MTV.
And I flew back to Canada without telling them that I was coming back.
We had the MTV
prop department come with us,
prop designers,
we look food back to Ottawa with like a crew of like 12 people or something like
that without telling my parents I was back in town,
we were there for a few days without my parents even knowing was there,
built these uh,
statues of my parents having sex
out of like,
you know,
plaster and stuff like that were really,
I think they cost like $5,000 to me or something like that.
Got MTV money,
you know,
and put them on the front lawn of their house and you know,
there was like a hose running up my dad's leg and water squirting out to where
it's supposed to and you know,
all over.
And um,
they were furious about that one.
So that was the line that across into
a lawsuit type of,
we talked about lawsuit,
like that was the first time it got to that place where we got back to New York.
They called it left a message on the answering machine answering machine.
They had an answering machine at MTV,
they left a message saying,
you know,
if,
if you,
my dad said a,
what was it?
He said,
if you ere that clip,
we're to sue you.
MTV bastards for $1 million was this will allow and um,
and uh,
was this threat.
And uh,
so MTV said I couldn't air the clip.
This was all like the first,
okay.
Couple of months of doing the show.
And uh,
I wasn't allowed to air that clip of the sec statues and MTV wasn't gonna let me
hear it unless my parents signed a release form.
My parents were like,
literally my mother was not talking to me.
And like right when that happened,
I told them,
I told the story a few times,
but not,
not too many times,
but like,
so I don't know if I've ever told you the story about the right before.
Um,
uh,
you know,
my mother was not talking to me and they were literally,
I actually think they were considering some sort of legal thing cause my,
I didn't realize like my mother is kind of conservative.
Like,
I didn't realize that.
And so,
no,
I had been doing these pranks for a few years now,
but it was this sort of the sexual undertone or overt sexual nature of the bit
that really,
really embarrassed her,
you know?
And she was really,
really,
really mad and upset.
Um,
and I felt bad.
Uh,
but it was hilarious.
The bit was hilarious.
I mean,
it really was hilarious.
So I did want to air it and I kind of felt like my mother was overreacting
because like,
you know,
it's just,
it's just a statue.
You know what I mean?
It's not,
it's fine.
But,
um,
so,
uh,
if things are getting really bad and then it was the weirdest timing,
but,
and this is how we're,
the show was sort of,
to talk about how weird it was.
Oprah calls the show and wants to book my parents and I on her mother's Day
special,
I,
so I called my mother,
been living in New York for maybe two months.
She's not talking to me,
my dad,
I say,
God put mom on the phone.
Let me let her listen.
I say,
Oprah wants us to go on a mother's Day special,
you know,
did she wants to play the slot immobile,
she wants to play painting the house,
you know,
and,
uh,
and she's got this whole plan to apologize to you guys on my behalf.
And so although she,
she of course was very impressed,
you know,
everybody's mom loves Oprah,
right?
Yeah.
So we flew to Chicago,
did the show.
Oprah then surprises me and them and gives them a all expenses paid two week
cruise to Tahiti.
Okay.
The whole audience,
you know,
cheers.
Like,
you know,
once she gives away stuff and then,
uh,
and then,
um,
that's cool.
And then that night at dinner,
uh,
you know,
I pulled the release form out of my back pocket.
They signed and,
uh,
the Sec statue bet aired on MTV.
That's all.
It's a thank you Oprah.
Thank you very much.
Yeah.
Oh,
bro.
Yeah.
But,
um,
yeah.
So,
yeah,
those were crazy times,
but,
you know,
I guess it was,
look,
I mean,
it was a,
it was a very strange time because,
you know,
uh,
I,
I sometimes admit like,
you know,
I try,
I'm trying to find an ex,
well,
Mr. Holmes,
I'm trying to find a way to like talk about my feelings about that period
because,
you know,
I don't know if,
I don't know if you have regrets in life,
you know,
I mean,
I,
I've,
I've started like hearing people talk about like,
Oh,
you know,
uh,
don't have regrets because every failure is actually something that you learn
from and then you learn from that and that makes you who you are and all that.
So start trying to like,
tell myself that and like,
you know,
but,
um,
but you know,
like it is kind of a mind fuck,
you know,
like,
like going through that because sure.
All of a sudden you're thinking,
okay,
shit,
like,
you know,
I'm going to Oprah and Letterman and uh,
they asked me to host Saturday night live,
right.
I'm,
I was directing my movie.
Freddy got fingered.
Yeah.
And,
uh,
that I wrote,
I'd never written a movie,
you know,
I don't know,
read a movie,
but for some reason,
like I thought,
oh,
I'm going to write a movie as opposed to go do a perfectly good movie than other
people who are professional movie writers make that are asking me to do.
And I'm like,
so like naive and like overconfident that I'm actually going to myself,
oh no,
no,
I don't want to do your movie that's like professional and like,
you know,
made and like really,
really good because that's not my kind of comedy.
You know,
I,
I doing something different here and then me and my friends sit down in a room
with absolutely no knowledge of how to write a movie,
right.
And Go,
we're going to make the craziest fucking movie ever made.
Right.
And so we go to this movie and you sort of,
you know,
are running on this sort of like adrenaline excitement and a,
and a bit of like kind of fear cause you're kind of go like shit.
Like I hope nobody like figures out that I actually don't know how to make a
movie.
Of course they did.
There were making it in,
are you saying that that's your regret then?
No,
I think,
I think I like,
so I think to myself sometimes I think like,
okay,
if I had been less naive maybe I would have done things differently and who
knows what would have,
would have been different,
you know,
like,
but uh,
you know,
I think,
I think I would've,
I wish I could have just sort of gone with the flow a little bit more at some
times.
Like when I hosted Saturday night live,
you know,
there was a bit of like,
I don't know if you'd call it controversy,
but there's some people were kind of like,
you know,
kind of,
I dunno,
little pissed at me over there I think.
And because of your status.
Well,
no,
what happened was I went to Saturday night live and I thought,
okay,
well I,
my friend Derrick and my friend Shawn friends from high school and their writers
on the show,
you know,
we're all friends,
we're not really writers.
You know,
we're calling ourselves writers now,
but you know,
we're not really writers at the time now.
Now they are writers.
Actually,
they could go,
both got big careers as writers in television up in Canada.
And,
but at the time we weren't really writers,
we were just friends and we started the show and everything was going great.
And Saturday night live asked me to come host it.
And I'm like completely like flabbergasted that I'm getting to host Saturday
night live and nervous as shit about it,
you know.
And then I say,
uh,
I say to,
you know,
Saturday night live,
I say,
is it all right if my friends come
okay?
And helped me write some clips,
some bits for the show saw?
They're like,
yeah,
sure.
So the open up a little office and uh,
for my two friends and I,
and we go down,
this is not what you're supposed to do though when you host Saturday night live,
if you're supposed to go down and be friends with everybody and go meet with all
the writers and,
and,
and do the bets.
But I had decided in my head like,
oh no,
we're gonna make it a crazy episode of Saturday night live,
you know?
Right.
And so I thought everybody would think that that was really cool.
But I guess some people thought like that.
I was like,
like kind of being disrespectful or something like that.
Yeah.
But as I want it to make this show like really,
really crazy,
you know?
That's who you are though.
Yeah.
You do.
I think to myself,
oh,
maybe it would have been better if I just went in and did the sketches that they
wrote and,
and sat and had fun.
You do none of the sketches.
I did quite a few of them.
Yeah.
But I did also,
like,
we also wrote a bunch of sketches that they let go on the air and they were like
really fucking weird sketches,
you know what I mean?
Like,
I don't even know if they were actually considered,
could be considered sketches to be honest with you.
Like it was like,
you know,
one was a mean will Farrell dressed up as eagles.
And,
uh,
we're in front of a green screen and there's like a,
an eagle's nest behind us and we're in these elaborate eagle costumes and,
uh,
Jimmy Fallon has at on the stage,
you know,
with another green screen and he's looking through binoculars at the eagles and
then it cuts to us as the eagles.
And then we basically,
you know,
like fly up into the audience and we'd go up into the audience and then we like
chew up carrots and like split them into each other's mouths or something like
that,
you know?
Yeah.
But I mean,
a lot of that I'm on board.
Let's do it.
Yeah.
So,
you know,
it was weird shit like that.
And,
uh,
so then another thing that happened was,
okay,
so
yeah,
you do a rehearsal show and um,
and uh,
they do a bunch of sketches that don't end up on the actual show.
Okay.
Uh,
cause you know you do more sketches and so I'm one of the sketches in the
rehearsal show was um,
oh shit,
I just forgot what I was going to say.
There's,
there's,
there's a,
there was some sketch we did in the,
in the rehearsal show that was just really,
yeah
it got cut.
There's this,
there's a lot of stories about the shoulder.
I had a major mental block there.
Right?
There come,
it'll come.
Yeah.
No I hear you.
But I think part of your success and the fact that you're a pioneer doing this
stuff,
it is your ability to be so tunnel vision and to really see and know what you
were great at.
I think my mental block just now was I started feeling weird talking about
myself.
Oh.
Oh well we're loving way.
Love it.
That's the point of this
podcast.
I'm here to talk about myself dying to hear this.
They love,
I get self conscious sometimes cause you know,
it's like,
you know,
fuck off buddy.
No
talking about himself.
But like,
you know,
it was um,
yeah,
it was a
one sketch.
Let me,
let me,
let me tell you a couple of schedule themselves.
One sketch was I want to see this SNL episode.
There was one sketch where I get in a bathtub with Lorne Michaels and they had
like,
uh,
a sketch written for us.
This was pre-taped sketch.
Yeah.
And uh,
so we did the sketch and then when the sketch was done,
I said to Lorne Michaels,
uh,
Lauren,
can I try improvising something?
This is a pre tape,
right.
And saw everyone's all nervous on the set too.
It's all quiet and sort of,
everyone's was pretty tense on the set over there.
For some reason I'm very serious.
And uh,
he was like,
oh,
okay,
sure Tom.
So I look,
do this.
I just basically start thrashing around.
There was no sketch.
I just start thrashing or there was a rubber ducky,
ducky,
Ducky,
splashing,
water splashing.
And I go on and on and on and on.
And then I just stopped.
And then Lauren goes,
Lauren had some line that he threw out there and was killed.
He had a funny line of sort of making fun of me for being an idiot.
And then that that ended up running,
you know?
So then I guess some of the writers who wrote the sketch that didn't like end up
actually running because of this thing that I improvised.
I just think people started getting like kind of like bummed that I was like
running around trying to do and all this.
Yeah.
Improvising and shit.
You know,
people get precious about it.
Yeah.
I mean that's all I remember the,
I remember the story that I'm a,
I hear this story I was going to tell when,
um,
when I got self conscious about talking about myself too much and forgot what
the story was.
So there's a,
in the rehearsal show,
uh,
this show,
the sketch actually ended up bearing and the rehearsal show,
there was a sketch where I play a wizard.
This was one of the ones that they wrote.
It was will Ferrell,
Molly,
Shannon and myself and I'm a wizard,
I think we're all wizards or something like that.
And for whatever reason they have me holding a potbelly pig,
live potbelly pig.
And um,
okay
I have like one line in the sketch.
Okay.
A couple of lines and then welfare,
let's rub a monologue for will.
And um,
I noticed in that rehearsal show that like if you hold the pig and your finger
to sort of lightly grazes at stomach,
it starts squealing like a,
like a maniac.
Like it's the craziest and the,
and the trainer comes up and says,
oh don't,
don't touch it.
Stomach it.
They go crazy when they do that.
And I mean it's like literally sounds like,
you know,
it sounds like it's not doing well but it doesn't hurt it or anything like that.
But it's like,
like really crazy and really loud here.
So I go like note to self,
don't do that in the rehearsal show.
Save it for the,
yeah.
Cause I'm like,
I like when things go wrong on television.
Sure.
And you know,
I don't think they liked that at Saturday night.
I like it when things get a little like fucked up.
Right.
Yeah.
Cause to me that's when like you sort of see like,
you know,
some,
some confusion and stuff.
So then there's the live show happens when we go on and,
and you know,
of course the sketch starts and I immediately began to sort of lightly caressing
her stomach and the thing just screams through the,
and we're alive and things screamed through the whole,
the whole a sketch and um,
you know,
I mean I thought it was pretty funny,
but,
uh,
I don't know if they,
I don't know if they liked that too much.
Um,
I don't know if,
I don't know if they liked that too much.
And so like I kind of like when I say like,
Oh,
I have some regrets and because I was naive,
right?
Yeah.
So now,
you know,
20 years later or whatever,
18 years later,
whatever it is,
you know,
I look back and go like,
oh,
you know,
maybe I shouldn't have been a shit disturber there in that moment because like
maybe you know,
like,
you know,
people like,
think I'm an asshole or something like that.
Cause I made the pig squeal when,
you know,
uh,
so,
you know,
it's like,
things like that.
But I also feel like
that's,
I mean,
what you're talking about too is just like comes with age and maturing and you,
you know,
you having the perspective you have now.
Yeah.
It just,
it doesn't make sense then.
No,
I say fuck him.
Tom Green.
Yeah.
You did the right thing.
You know why that was your brand.
That's who they fucking hired.
That's the,
that was your thing when you went in being you to 100%.
You know what I mean?
I think he knew what they were.
Yeah.
Getting you mentioned in your email when you invited me that you thought it was
a nice person.
Nice.
So,
you know,
I appreciate that.
But I think part of the reason why I'm a nice person is because maybe I feel
like I have to compensate for maybe haven't been an asshole at some point.
You know,
like when I was younger,
like maybe,
you know,
maybe when I made that pig squeal and fucked up that sketch,
like maybe I shouldn't have done that.
Maybe I'd better be nice to people.
And I learned from that.
Do you think that people have that?
Um,
you know,
from watching the sketches and knowing your persona that there's a little,
they have a little bit of apprehension or fear like,
is this guy going to be a dick?
[inaudible] fuck with me.
They do.
Right.
I think so.
Yeah.
It took me while to figure that out.
Cause sometimes I thought sometimes I perceive it as like people might not like
me or something,
but then,
then I think maybe they're just worried that I'm going to pull a dead raccoon
out of my pants and throw it on him or something like that.
So,
yeah.
Yeah.
I mean,
I get very nervous around,
you know,
people that I,
I get nervous when I meet you guys,
you know,
for the first time I'm looking at what I'm said,
what am I going to say?
You know?
Yeah.
And I get nervous when I go to the comedy store and,
and you know,
you're backstage and there's,
oh,
David spades going on,
you know,
and I'm like,
oh my God.
Like there's David spade right there.
You know,
I'm kind of nervous,
you know?
Sure.
You know,
so,
and that doesn't really go away.
I did this,
you know,
Internet show,
like this,
uh,
for years in my living room a few years ago and interviewed tons of people.
And I honestly think I kind of stopped doing it because it was,
I had too much anxiety about having to meet the people that were coming up.
I'd be like,
Oh shit,
we invited val Kilmer and he's coming,
I'm going to have to sit with val Kilmer for now.
Oh my God,
I don't,
what the fuck am I going to do?
You know?
And then I'd let it up having anxiety about it all week.
Yeah.
You know,
so I just kind of like,
now I just,
my podcast,
I just walk around,
you know,
just talking to a microphone by myself.
Yeah.
I don't know.
I'm just throwing it out there.
Do you think that that's why maybe you would soda,
you know,
attack,
not attack people,
but you're the one that kind of threw out that to prevent?
I think I had,
I think I definitely have sort of a,
you know,
when,
when you,
when I was a kid I was like super skinny kid,
you know,
we were,
I was an army brat,
so we moved every year.
I was always very insecure about,
you know,
myself.
And I think that was sort of my self defense mechanism was like trying to be
like outrageous and,
and you know like,
Oh,
you know,
you can't make fun of me in the hallway because I just crashed into a garbage
can and like,
you know,
fell into a bookshelf,
and obviously I did it on purpose.
So now you can't make fun of kind of make fun of me hitting me an idiot because
clearly I'm trying to be an idiot.
Yeah.
So I mean,
moving does that,
I remember I moved a lot as a kid too.
Especially like when you start to come into,
you know,
that like 12,
13,
14 year old age,
why did you move so much?
Born in Cincinnati,
we moved a lot when you were in Florida,
you were in Minneapolis and blocky and different schools sometimes within those
cities.
You know,
why didn't you move so much though?
My Dad was just getting a promoted within the company he was working in.
Okay.
And so they would just,
you know,
he would just,
we would just move.
But Yeah,
God,
those,
I like those feelings resonate with me about being,
moving around and,
and the older I got,
I feel like the harder those moves where,
you know,
we moved middle of my freshman year of high school.
See,
we stopped,
I stopped moving when I was seven,
so,
oh yeah,
we moved to Ottawa when
I was seven and then I stayed there.
So yeah.
So I just moved every year before that,
before that first grade,
second grade.
Oh my God.
How do you feel then we got,
we almost tabbed on this earlier,
but how do you feel about it?
Cause I do feel like you really laid the groundwork for us certain style of
comedy that I feel like is very much yours,
you know?
Um,
when you,
do you feel like sometimes you're like,
oh,
this person's doing kind of my thing.
Like,
okay.
Yeah.
I mean,
I,
I mean I,
I honestly like does it feel cool?
They're like,
you're getting,
it's a tough one to answer because like,
I know everybody.
Yeah.
And you know,
everybody that does it blatantly,
you know,
has expressed to me that they're fans of mine and I'm fans of theirs too.
Yeah.
And we're friends.
Um,
and I get asked about this,
you know,
when I do press,
when I'm on the road,
are people asking you about all the shows and
you know,
okay,
I have a problem with it.
When they do the exact bit,
the I doing the same bid and there's a lot of people that have done every one of
my bits.
There's a few,
there's a couple of shows,
big shows everyone knows,
probably won't talking about.
They've done every single one of my bits,
like the exact bid,
like painted the parent's house,
you know,
put the animals in the house,
went out and pretend to they were,
you know,
so.
So when I see them doing the exact bit for me it's,
it's a little hard to,
that's not paying on mine because it's like I go like,
I remember when we came up with that,
my friends and I came up with painting my parents' house and thinking herself,
Okay Shit.
Like no one's ever fucking done that before.
Yeah.
Painted their parents house and filmed it and got their reactions.
Like no one's ever done that before.
Like,
so we were always trying to come up with things that nobody had ever done
before.
That was literally the mantra.
Like,
we're looking,
you know,
look for,
like sucking milk out of a cow's udder for instance.
Not something like that is probably one of my cleverest bits,
but,
you know,
no,
I saw somebody big show last week on Instagram doing that and I'm like,
exactly.
You know,
I'm like,
oh,
okay,
lets you know if you want to do that exact bit,
that's fine.
But I feel it's a little bit,
uh,
a little bit weird.
Yeah.
That's a little odd.
It's like everybody gets really,
really uptight in stand up when somebody's like,
you know,
oh,
they both did a bit about like landlines.
You know what I mean?
You know that Guy Tom totally stole that bit where it's like,
well,
you know what I mean?
That's sort of like this about three member then Moran Mess.
Yeah.
But when it's like shot for shot,
you know,
the same thing.
Totally different.
And,
and,
and when there's,
when there's,
you know,
not dozens but like literally like,
almost,
you know,
there's a hundred bits.
Sure.
Exactly.
Same.
You start to go on.
It's kind of unfair,
you know?
But,
um,
then at the same time,
you know,
I've,
I've gone through phases of how I deal with this emotionally.
Initially I was angry about it when I first started seeing that,
and then I got tired of being angry about it.
So I started being more kind of like,
oh yeah,
we're all,
you know,
doing the,
we all inspired by things.
And then lately I'm kind of a little bit more like,
no,
I'm just going to talk about it.
You know,
I'm just gonna talk about it,
you know,
cause I,
I look,
I,
you know,
my line for a few years when asked about this was,
um,
you know,
I was inspired by Letterman,
right.
Letter would yell out of his office with a megaphone.
Yeah.
So then I want it to go out in the street with a megaphone.
Right.
So that's kind of a broad thing,
but it's a little different when it's like mid forbid a planned out thing is
different.
Even Straight Jack Dude,
like,
yeah,
but it's true,
but it's like,
you know,
I don't,
I don't like to,
uh,
appear
bitter about it.
I got you.
I'll tell you one thing that I just realized like,
and he's sitting here talking to you about that.
That I feel like the feeling that I'm most excited me that I still,
I think probably is what clicks with people too about that time about fucking
with your parents is how much joy so many of us get from fucking with our own
parents.
Yeah.
And that's really like seeing your dad's face when he saw the slut tmobile.
What,
what happens to me is that I feel like I'm looking at kind of a representation
of all of our parents,
that guy,
kind of a conservative guy,
probably a good person does the right thing and they're,
they're good examples to us.
Like my parents,
they're good people,
but I know they're good people and I know what their sensibility is and I know
where their lines are and I think everybody kind of gets a thrill out of poking
your parents.
Like I still love upsetting my parents to a degree.
Yeah.
I love getting that reaction.
I love calling my mom and just burping on the phone and have her be like,
ah,
you're so disgusting.
And he's hearing,
hearing her disappointment in me being gross is a thrill still to this day,
you know?
And I feel like what you did like that kind of represented that to all of us
watching it like oh yeah,
like it's ups like something to upset your parents
and you know how you can push them and you know where you can push them exactly.
That ultimately,
even if you push them a little bit too far,
you know
it's okay.
They're not going to call the cops probably.
Yeah.
I sent my mother,
um,
she was like,
I sent her a picture of our baby and she wrote bag.
It's so beautiful.
And then I sent her a picture of um,
an elephant reaching into or as a gift,
you know,
reaching into another elephant's ass,
pulling out a piece of shit and eating it.
That happens.
That I guess that have happened.
That's something that happens because there's a little,
there's a Gif of it.
Yeah.
Well fenced aren't as smart as harassment
and she got sick.
She was like,
you know,
she's like,
this is a new low even for you.
And like it was like a little bit of a rant and it made me laugh so hard.
So then I just looked up more animal shit things and just send stuff like that
to your mother.
It's funny because she's,
she's offended on multiple levels.
One level she's offended by what you sent,
but then she's also offended that you would send that to your mother.
Yeah.
And then she's offended that she didn't do her job as a mother to have somebody
that would do this to their mother.
Feels like Ellis.
We have a two and a half year old Kiddo and he loves to go into my purse and get
the brightest red lipstick and paint the walls and we've caught them doing it
and he knows to get my attention it's got to do is go to the Paris,
look at me like I'm going to fucking do this.
And then I yell at him and he runs away with the person.
It's a fun game.
Look at me,
mommy,
I might be naughty painting your house.
He's already a prankster on your hands.
This guy,
you think this is a Tom Green fan here?
Hi Yah.
Yah,
Yah.
No,
no,
no.
My mother fucking name.
First Day out.
Let's get it.
First Day out,
I ain't playing no motherfucking game.
I'm back on our block.
Slipped in and in that mother fucking coke cane.
I'm Bryce silver.
I got these gold chains around my neck and these diamonds in my ears.
You can have full full lace should I essential shots and make your fucking
disappear.
Wow.
That's Brian's silver.
Oh yeah.
He's got a big Instagram following
online.
He talks a lot of shit as you can see.
Absolutely.
And apparently he got locked up for something.
No.
Yeah,
yeah.
This,
this is his literal first day out.
So he's one,
he's one of your regular callers or we've featured him before.
He's a star of your mom's house.
Is he like interact with the,
with the show here?
No,
he's not one who interacts well.
Yeah.
This is the best thing is that this was his first day out.
And on his first day out video,
he announced that he's selling cocaine.
Oh,
my trademarks and motherfucking child to take my shit.
Guess what bitch,
you ain't nothing but a motherfucking trick.
Lick his shit off my motherfucking feet.
I'll bet.
Exactly.
Y'All go ahead and tell them mother fucking friend
Juno award nominee here.
No,
I'm back.
Yeah,
exactly.
I mean,
would he have made it in the group?
Yeah,
he would've.
He would've.
Yeah.
Oh,
glad.
I feel like I'm looking at mine 40 in an AK 47 I'd make your head don't
motherfucking back lit.
Yeah.
She rapped about,
you know,
uh,
Kinda,
I mean,
are we were pretty nerdy.
we were much nerdier than this guy.
This guy's now got the tax,
the gold,
the cocaine,
you know,
we didn't,
we didn't have the cocaine.
People might call him a culture vulture,
you know,
so
we were like appropriating,
we were more trying to be like Beastie boys.
Right.
But,
uh,
but we were kind of staying in your lane,
varying your white layer.
Very Canadian Canada.
We weren't even from Toronto.
That's how,
you know.
Right,
right.
I was like the least hardcore place to be from,
but you guys were celebrated.
Uh,
you know,
we had,
uh,
you know,
again,
like
we were kind of Nerdy,
you know,
um,
and,
uh,
you know,
I,
I made all these songs and we,
I managed to convince a and m records Canada to give us this record deal.
Unbelievable.
When the record came out,
we're in Toronto,
we went,
did a show in Toronto and you know,
the hardcore Toronto urban hip hop community,
which exists in,
is real and was,
was,
was not happy that,
that this sort of,
uh,
you know,
nerdy white group from Ottawa got a record deal,
when,
you know,
where did we come from,
kind of thing.
And we did the show once in Toronto and you know,
we had a song that was called check Theo or was the numerous on check the,
your trek,
the Organized Ryan was,
aren't being met.
And it was like the song was,
the course was check the,
or you like it so far,
right.
Nerdy,
right?
And,
uh,
so then,
you know,
we went and performed at the show and this other rap group went on before us and
they were like,
they had guns.
Okay.
And they were,
they the,
the revealed the guns.
Like we saw the guns and this is Canada.
Like nobody's got guns in Canada.
Right?
But these guys had guns and they were there,
their rap was fuck the,
Oh,
are we hate it so far.
Rightly did before us.
Right?
And then there's like total beef thing and then we would,
then we went on stage and perform in front of this,
you know,
all hip hop crowd and um,
how'd you do?
We were basically the only white people that are basically,
which is fine,
but it was like,
you know,
and half the audience did not like,
I have so much anxiety right now.
Half the audience liked us because they were sort of down with our crew because
we got signed with this band called the dream warriors,
which were,
you know,
a real band and Toronto that were popular.
Uh,
but then the other half that goes sort of like rival gangs and stuff,
you know,
we have that in Canada.
A guy was pointing a gun at me while I was on stage.
Oh my God.
I was trying to be like,
and it had,
I remember I had it had tape on it because he'd publicly used it so much that it
broke.
Yeah.
And,
uh,
and uh,
and then,
uh,
then they were,
people were grabbing me while I was on stage and pulling me to the crowd and
punching me in the head basically.
And we kept rapping.
We did this whole thing.
It was,
it was,
it was at this,
it was called the barbecue.
It was what it was called.
And it was,
uh,
basically this underground like hip hop,
you know,
venue.
And,
uh,
then we had to get like sort of like rushed through the crowd after everyone's
taking punches at us and stuff.
It was Bruce pretty cool.
It actually felt very exciting at the time.
But,
uh,
I have a feeling like if I looked like that guy,
they might've been more acceptive maybes that hey fucking that guys a little
more.
I'm
back.
Oh,
I said once,
I ain't going to say in a motherfucking game.
I got these motherfucking Fufu ass motherfuckers ignore me on my motherfucking
pace saying all this dumb ass bullshit as shit.
That's some shit.
I need to buy some bits on.
Dr Phil.
Man.
Fuck that shit.
I was in motherfucking prison Nigga.
Yeah,
there you go.
Yeah.
It's a big word there,
a big word,
but that his art has evolved.
I remember the first time we met Brian,
so he was,
yeah,
he was shirtless.
So I have a funny question.
We are good at a party like time we discovered these weed.
We did a,
a weird porn segment last.
Oh,
okay.
And that was uh,
uh,
that's race porn,
race play point.
You heard of this?
No,
no.
This way were they have a play form.
This is what,
Oh,
okay.
How you play.
Well,
cool.
So I have a funny question to ask you guys.
As Nicole by I say the n word,
it turns me on
this idea of word.
I'm Yo Nigga
Love Dick.
Yeah.
It's pretty intense.
It's 20 questions.
Yeah,
that's right.
Well,
yeah,
it's very habit.
It's funny that it starts with,
I have a funny question.
It's funny question.
It's interesting that we're living in a world now where like you can sort of
instantly access a soundbite of virtually any combination of words no matter how
unlikely.
Yeah.
And it's all immediately at your fingertips.
There was also,
um,
there was,
uh,
a nine 11.
Wow.
US military forces are wow.
Nine,
11 porn.
Yup.
Then there's Osama,
and I don't want to see how this ends.
Thank you.
I'll be looking it up later.
But,
um,
uh,
there was a disabled porn,
which is apparently a huge genre.
Yeah.
With,
I mean,
there's everything from stumps and,
um,
you know,
canes completely.
People who have zero ability to move.
Yeah.
And somebody doesn't sound right.
Does it?
Uh,
servicing them?
Yeah.
And then,
and then there's like,
I gotta go pee pee in my died.
He's literally go there on the show,
right.
Like,
I'm sorta ramped up to this.
So you didn't come out of the gate with the diaper porn,
but,
uh,
we're sort of
loosened up a little bit now.
I can.
Yeah.
I mean,
you've been here for now hyper porn.
No,
that's cool.
Yeah,
I mean it's definitely like a,
you know,
I'm in a position here of a half to really kind of figure like,
how am I supposed to react?
You know,
cause like,
you know,
but it look us cause uh,
yeah,
it is kind of awesome.
Lee,
the world we're living in now,
it's pretty crazy.
Yeah.
And uh,
I don't think like,
you know,
I mean I talk about this too much about,
I'm 47 so,
you know,
I clearly have a very clear and real memory of no Internet.
You know,
I'm not no internet but no video on the Internet.
Sure.
So,
you know,
and I'll,
I was always very fascinated by crazy videos because there was very few of them,
of course.
So,
you know,
when I was in high school or even elementary spaces as a dad,
right.
Faces of death.
Right.
So that was the only thing that was like weird like that,
you know.
Oh,
are those,
um,
and they also had like weird spaces at death,
which was like kind of [inaudible] was another one.
Yeah,
I remember.
Um,
basically,
but there was mixed tapes of outrageous shit.
I love like James Brown interview,
right?
Yeah.
CNN where he's coked out and he's like,
Shit like that.
And would cut together.
Would pass around VHS.
Yeah.
It wasn't one that,
who was pissing on some girl.
Now your breath smells like piss.
Oh,
wow.
The Guy,
he uh,
he's like,
I kiss you but your breath smells like piss.
Yeah.
Huge.
In my high school hearted farted in that girl face.
Yes.
Blowing him.
And he was like,
Oh,
did I far?
And she's like,
yeah.
He's like,
yeah,
that happens sometimes.
It's the,
what's the Grand Guitar Rock?
Barry Barry Barry is chuck Barry Barry was,
should I get mixed up with Chuck Barris sex tapes that they would be confiscated
during a raid?
It was a drug raid that the DEA did.
It was like a nonsense,
I think raid.
Yeah.
They've found that the VHS tapes were confiscated during the raid and then they
got leaked and he liked,
he was like,
he pissed on this girl.
He's like,
he pisses on her in the table and he's like,
damn,
you smell like piss now.
Like,
yeah,
you just missed the heat on a downy.
He's like,
uh,
it was,
no,
he says,
I kiss you but your breath smells like piss.
Yeah.
And I was like,
yeah,
no.
What is that on the Internet?
Yeah.
That's on the other yet.
That is now on the Internet.
Oh yeah.
You want to see it?
Uh,
yeah.
Okay.
I mean,
I dunno,
like maybe,
maybe,
maybe not.
Okay.
Maybe I want to see it.
But uh,
you want to,
I'll,
I'll do describe it.
Well,
no,
I just,
I was going to say,
why don't I just email you later.
Sends me later.
Okay.
Yeah.
I don't want to,
I don't want to appear as if I want to see it.
I got you.
Yeah.
Even though I do want maybe want to see it later.
Allie method.
I don't want to be seen wanting to see it.
You know,
we were discussing right before you came,
this guy who's clearly a kind of young guy is making a video,
uh,
where he's reviewing strippers at detail.
I hate this stripper experiences.
No,
but she's like,
one of the things she says is like,
what compels someone to do this?
And I go,
well,
you know what,
there's an age range and I think it's about 17 to 22 where testosterone
is raging so intensely through us as men.
That in his mind it's like just talk about sex.
Even though I know it's not good to do it in this video,
but because I'm so oversexed talking about it in some way is going to help me.
Maybe it'll lead to sex.
You know,
it's like he's just
had an interaction with an Ethiopian stripper name of Alisay.
She was,
you know,
we really danced.
We really grind.
I like girls,
I like to dry sex is fun.
It's fine.
I don't get,
I'm not,
but you know,
just some contacts with [inaudible] dropped down to her knees a few times and
play with my dick through my shorts.
Basketball weren't basketball strip club.
I'm wearing basketball shorts to the strip club.
It was fine.
You know,
I think she likes my deck.
Yes.
Well it's a thing like,
you know,
guys,
probably,
what is he in his twenties or something and he looks,
he looks not as good because he,
he should definitely not rock the horse shoe at his age.
He should just,
you know,
buzz it down,
but he's going to like it.
He's going to be 40 someday.
Yeah.
This video's going to be out there on the Internet probably,
right?
Yeah.
Oh yeah.
Or is,
is he able to delete this?
No,
no,
no.
We're not helping.
Oh,
right,
right.
Yeah.
It's permanently on your,
yeah.
So he might not have been thinking of that,
that he was going to go viral.
Um,
and uh,
there's gonna be a lot of people with a lot of regret.
I think the world in about 20 years from now,
it used to just be people in
porn will be like,
oh,
I have a video that I hope no one sees.
And now here's the thing though,
is the fact that there's so many people with so many videos that they're going
to regret just going to kind of lesson.
Yeah.
Our access to shame.
Yeah,
exactly.
There's no shame in the culture anymore.
Everybody's oversharing all the fucking time.
Which is interesting what you were saying in the 90s I mean before the Internet.
Yeah,
there was just like a handful of these Weirdos and you cherish this weird crap
and now you're like,
is everybody mentally ill?
Like are most people just fucking nutty?
And we didn't know it.
Well,
even like that look
like a decorum,
the way that even like the president talks and you know,
handles himself and does press.
It's a total shift.
And it's also,
maybe it's shifted things permanently because everything used to be very,
I mean even in honestly until a couple of years ago,
the president would say things very structured.
It would feel like a rehearsed.
Yeah.
Almost always positioned.
It was as if he knew what he was talking about or something.
Right.
And now it's just,
he's,
you know,
he's just like,
I don't give a fuck.
It's like the idiocrasy,
it's sort of like,
uh,
you know,
the only way to break through,
I guess the,
the din of all of this information now is to say something wrong,
you know,
just to sort of essentially do something shocking.
Um,
but like I,
I kinda like,
I,
I agree.
Like it's kind of like,
it's so,
there's so much of it now.
Yeah.
In a way,
it's kind of why I sort of stop doing videos.
Like even though I made,
may do another,
this is empty now,
but I don't know,
I may do another version of a,
my show,
by the way,
I'm really not,
I'm not actually able to announce it officially yet,
but I am talking to fun little television channel about bringing back the Tom
Green show in some capacity through that would be so often going to be
interesting because it is a different,
you know,
the different world now.
You know,
like,
you know,
it's like you said,
like,
you know,
we welcome watch,
all of this crazy stuff now.
So I think that's kind of big was a big motivator for me to actually start doing
standup again.
You know,
cause I,
I realized like that's something that you can't just sort of,
you know,
people can't just copy that.
Yeah.
You know,
it's,
it's a,
you know,
you have to get up on stage and you have to be able to do it.
Yeah.
So,
um,
that's why I think I've actually been really kind of,
you know,
really focusing and enjoying doing standup.
Like that's pretty much all I do now is I just travel,
do standup.
I next week I'm in New Jersey,
the stress factory.
I'm a stressed factory.
I'm in Providence,
Rhode Island for one night or,
and they have stress factory than I'm at governor's for one night or a nice long
island,
Boston and Laugh Boston coming up.
And I wouldn't tell you this if I just wouldn't bring this up.
You're probably the only guy that took a break from standup that I hear people
comics compliment all the time.
Oh,
well yes.
Well that's nice to hear.
Thank you for telling me that.
Absolutely.
Yeah.
And I remember when you started like really doing spots probably a few years
ago,
right?
Like when you,
you know,
you've,
you've been added again for awhile now,
but when you really,
seven or eight years.
Yeah,
yeah.
I would say maybe like four years ago.
Yeah.
Um,
I,
you know,
you hearing in green rooms,
people like,
you know,
Tom Green started doing standup again and you're like,
yeah,
how has it,
everybody was like,
compliment.
Oh,
that's really good to hear.
Cause I,
I,
you know,
you don't know what people say,
but of course it's like,
it's,
uh,
you know,
I'm,
I feel fortunate that,
you know,
MTV pump my show out all over the world.
So that's given me a lot of opportunity to perform,
you know.
Sure.
So like,
I get to go,
you know,
I've done like Australia and I've just did,
England and stuff last year.
And I'm sort of always going and it's great because I'm kind of,
uh,
you know,
I don't have,
I don't have kids.
Uh,
uh,
you know,
not nuts.
I May,
I may
want to have kids someday.
I'm getting pretty old now,
but,
uh,
you know,
I,
I have a lot of free time,
you know,
so I'm able to just kind of keep going and uh,
it's been,
it's been amazing.
You're a great comic,
but I will not,
I will not tell you.
You're not the king of Improv.
I'll tell you who that is.
I am the king of Improv.
Do you know who that is?
Do you know who the self proclaimed King of Improv is?
Do you want to hear it again?
Sounded like Trump,
but can you play it again?
Mean I am the king of in province for,
for you.
Oh,
I get to play that one more time.
When I am the king of in province
Charlie Sheen or no,
here's another,
here's another hint
and it's like,
ah,
is that Drake?
No,
I dunno know.
Here's who it is.
It's the absolute king of self proclaimed King of Improv right here.
Oh,
Steven Seagal.
Oh really?
Have the highest hopes that I can be of some use to kind of try to get people to
have meaningful conversations and uh,
meaningful meetings with
now do you want to see him be super improvising here?
Yeah.
That was wearing the Kung Fu ogee.
Russia for interviews.
He does and he's wearing his villain glasses and just painted his hair and
goatee.
Dark black with a sharpie.
Nice and easy.
You do it in the bathroom and how black dye in his hair,
which looks perfect on a 60 something year old man.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
It doesn't look suspect at all.
Well,
let's watch him improvise.
We obviously spend a lot of time in Russia.
You spend a lot of time in America,
you're making films and so forth.
And in terms of your life in America,
you've been very much caught up in all the allegations of sexual harassment.
You had a rape allegation against you and I want to know,
hey,
look at that.
I didn't know where the checks,
you just improvise.
Take the microphone off.
You
go there.
And of course though,
we didn't respond there.
He has said previously he denies any allegations.
Yeah.
But that Improv was just like boom.
It was pretty cool.
You had that planned out I think.
Yeah.
It was kind of neat.
I didn't know,
uh,
where I kind of vaguely heard rumblings about the rape stuff.
I think I'd seen that,
uh,
that clip.
Oh really?
Recently?
Yeah.
It was the,
you know,
Steven Seagal man.
I mean,
I used to actually really like his movies under siege.
Sure.
Yeah.
I think that was the biggest box office hit,
but it started with like out for justice.
Hard to kill.
Yeah.
I used to watch those as a kid.
I loved the,
my Stepdad from India used to love Steven Seagal.
That was his favorite.
Yeah.
Who was telling us what a piece of shit he is the other day,
somebody about the biggest difference between directing him.
Like somebody directed him in that first one,
like hard to kill or out for justice can.
They were like,
this guy is just somebody,
like,
he was like,
uh,
a studio guys,
a workout trainer.
Like it was,
that's how it started.
Like somebody at paramount was like,
I need a workout.
And he
trained them and then they ended up making a movie with him and he was like the
nicest fucking guy.
And he goes,
and then like he did three other movies and then I directed him and something
else.
And they're like,
biggest piece of garbage,
like ever was to golf.
He just lost it.
Stunt guy lost his mind.
I talked to a couple of stunt guys shooting something and they were like,
man,
hands down.
The worst person I've ever worked with got was known for a purposely hitting
guys.
You know what?
I think breaking guys lose their mind a little bit when they get famous,
you know,
and then they like,
uh,
you know,
feel like maybe,
maybe,
I don't know if it's social anxiety,
they don't know how to deal with all the people talking to them or maybe they're
just assholes to begin with.
I think it's a little bit of that.
And,
uh,
you know,
cause it seems to happen a fair amount.
Not,
not,
no,
I wouldn't say all the time,
but like maybe half the time.
Yeah.
Thank you.
And whoever you are before fame just gets amplified.
Yeah.
I mean thankfully comics are kind of low key cause we get humbled constantly.
There's fewer asshole standup comics actors.
It seems to be.
Yeah.
Everyone seems pretty.
That's what,
that's what I,
I've been loving about doing sets around town and in Ela here it's like,
you know,
you get to interact with a lot of your,
uh,
your heroes,
you know?
Yeah.
Pretty cool.
It is pretty cool.
Yeah.
It's,
it's a,
it's pretty well,
you know.
That's cool.
So,
um,
amazing.
So like what's this,
that it's a good question.
Oh,
I know.
I know why that's built like that.
What is this?
Okay.
I know why this is felt like this.
So this right here used to be in that room and it was the guys production desk.
Oh,
okay.
I had all the different,
you know,
uh,
racks and everything in it.
Cause this is an actual recording studio.
It was an actual recording studio.
Amazing Room.
I this was going to have monitors on it at one point.
So the guy converted and stuff like drilled the hole.
Okay.
Yup.
Yeah.
He was like,
oh,
I'll make it turn so you can turn monitor.
Ah,
Nice.
I got to go one of these.
I have a little recording studio at home.
I'm making hip hop beats.
Getting back into,
you want me to put you in touch with Brian's Silva so that you can have a,
you can make the beats then he can get right.
Oh yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
I want to get him on a track for sure.
Yeah.
I mean be the next little pump.
That's right.
Calm little something for sure.
Yeah,
it'd be great.
You know,
but you guys are moving to a new studio though.
We are,
yeah.
Are you,
are you going to keep the studio here also?
So I'm sure not being here or in the other school,
this idea,
she likes to say,
but you were talking about converting this studio into a movie theater that
would be more fun.
And we may be still,
like what you could do is make it a movie theater room,
but just keep the mics out so you could sit around on the couches and do it here
without all the table and stuff.
So then if you ever don't feel like going in to the studio,
because I'll,
I'll tell you,
I look,
I,
I had a studio in my house.
Okay.
For both five years.
I call it web.
Oh,
vision.
You know,
we did the camera switcher,
everything.
And uh,
you know,
val Kilmer came up with the,
people come up to the house and,
and uh,
you know,
I,
I loved it.
And then at a certain point I was kind of like,
oh,
I,
I don't want to do it in the house.
Right.
So then I'm,
I moved the studio somewhere else and then,
um,
then I kind of like realized,
well I don't always want to have to go there either,
you know,
because then you got to drive all the way over there and you know,
it's like here it's like,
you know,
you guys wake up,
guest shows up,
do the thing and then I leave and you're still at home,
you know,
so like this but uh,
Gotcha.
Was there talking to you?
You're now right?
Yeah.
That's like your kids are sick or something.
I don't want to go drive.
I know.
Can't we just keep it up?
Tom Am I,
am I a I don't mean to,
oh,
so grossest person.
Somebody who has,
we got an email asking manscaping advice.
Maybe Tom can weigh in a says I got a question about cleaning up your
downstairs.
Tom Seems like the kind of person who has hair on most of his body and I happen
to suffer from the same affliction my lady friend doesn't like when it's super
bushy while she does mouth work.
So I try to keep it clean.
Yeah.
Here's where the problem lies.
I've shaved and just trim my fun hair numerous times.
Each time.
It doesn't match up with the remaining here on my stomach and legs.
I look neat and tidy until you glance up or down,
just right back to a gangly mess.
More than anything.
I just find it looks unsightly and frankly unpleasant.
So Todd is what they're calling me.
How do you deforest you're Peruvian jungle.
Best wishes.
Um,
Christine,
you were very funny.
I have you thought about giving standup comedy ago?
Go try it out regards Harry.
So Harry,
um,
I dunno,
like I do this thing where I'll use experiments to clarify.
He's saying it looks short on around your g twigs and berries and then it's so
long everywhere else that it's a disparity in the,
the length of the hair.
I mean it's,
I don't know,
man.
Are you shooting videos?
Who cares what it looks like?
Just trim it down.
And then I do find that like taking the razor till your junk.
Uh,
sometimes it's weird where it doesn't actually trim as much.
Like I see some hairs in the same spot and I go back with the razor and the
razor won't do it.
I have to like get clippers and razor to make it present.
I haven't really talked about,
but I've been doing something kind of weird lately.
Yeah.
Like I've been growing at real long and then braiding it.
That's cool.
I've got a little braids with little beads in it.
Yeah.
That's awesome.
It's just kind of something for you.
Braid from the top so that like the braids hanging over your junk.
Yeah,
there's like a multicolored and then do people part the brain does that.
I mean it's just,
it's just for myself.
It's not really for,
for anybody else.
Anyone else.
And do you braid the,
the sac and the taint hair as well?
It's all braids.
Different guides and things.
And I'm amazed at the length of some of my taint hair.
Yeah.
Like it's more like grout and he always wants me to look at scrum and talking
about that.
And the thing is,
it's such a request that Tom,
oh stop.
Don't ask him that.
His sweet girls here.
She doesn't want you asking him this.
She might want to know.
I don't know.
No.
Uh,
no.
You may have just opened up a Pandora's box.
There you go.
You know,
does she have,
do you ever ask that somebody or lady play with your self or no,
I have not.
Uh,
requested that.
Okay.
No.
How have you guys been dating?
Uh,
a few months.
Okay.
Oh,
it's coming up.
Okay.
I got you.
I got from my vapes or new love.
They don't do this nasty shit.
That's when that nasty shit happens.
Yeah.
But Times like Tom Cruise,
a nice man.
He doesn't Fart in front of women.
I'm guessing you're not gross like that.
Uh,
I don't make like I try,
I do try to not fart in front of people.
It's very nice.
But um,
yeah,
that's,
that's something I try to avoid doing.
Well,
my husband's the opposite,
but we were like a month into dating and he was sitting in his boxer shorts and
he put my hand in his crotch and farted on my hand.
It's a one month,
then that's 14 years.
Might have been a couple months in.
Yeah.
Well maybe is that when you knew this was Jesus Christ?
I know now at the moment you do that might say more about you then it says
low self esteem.
I advocate for you could have made the choice to just leave immediately.
Did Not do that to me around there are so many red flags that I ignored about
you.
He loves murder shows.
Do you watch murder shows?
Uh,
like you know,
like the,
where they're solving the,
the,
the on the,
yeah.
Yeah.
I watch those sometimes.
What's your favorite thing to watch?
Uh,
my favorite thing to watch.
Well,
let's see.
Um,
yeah,
I watch Netflix.
I was watching like,
you know,
look,
the shot the show the last few years,
I know,
looks probably shows people watched already,
like house of cards or like house of cards.
I guess you can't like that in horse.
Uh,
and breaking bad.
I,
I binge watched that.
Do you like better call Saul?
Yeah,
but I haven't seen that all yet cause so good.
Yeah.
I,
but I do,
I do a do like that,
a lot of what I want that's,
I've been meaning to watch that.
I honestly have not really been watching much television.
Uh,
lately I kind of watched,
see,
I was watching CNN basically unloop for about the last seven years and then this
year I kind of stopped watching it.
Like it's good to take a break from that,
cancelled my cable after the election.
Yeah.
Because I was just sort of,
uh,
over it and um,
and uh,
you know,
I kind of sort of felt like
I felt a little angry at CNN actually,
to be honest with you because I felt like the way they reported on,
you know,
not to get too political or anything,
but the way they reported on the election.
Yeah.
I believe,
like kind of influenced the outcome,
not just,
not just them,
but the entire media,
you know?
And it's sort of like angered me a little bit because you know,
when you're like,
when you work in television or you know,
when you've done a TV show,
which involves doing something shocking and then getting to people talk to talk
about it,
right.
You know,
you realize,
oh,
that's,
that's like a very real technique,
you know?
So that's what Trump was doing and that's what people are doing now.
It's like say something shocking and then the media,
which you,
you think would be like kind of aware of what was going on,
would maybe like report on things a little more.
Uh,
you know,
uh,
I don't,
I just feel like the way they,
they,
they took advantage of that,
not for the sake of journalism,
but for the sake of ratings,
you know?
And that's just sort of really bothered me because I used to,
I actually,
I actually used to think that CNN was like really reporting the news,
you know?
And now I sort of,
I definitely like have kind of,
I took me a while to,
to come to that conclusion that the Nomo it's,
they're just,
they're just in the ratings game thing.
I should have figured that out.
Jay sensationalizing things.
I don't think I quite wanted to believe that for most of my,
most of my life.
You know,
I thought,
oh no,
they're reporting the news and this is important that we know all this stuff.
And I think,
I think after nine 11 something happened in me where I,
because I'm a paranoid person.
Yeah.
I became extremely afraid that there was going to be some piece of news that I
didn't get quickly enough so that I would be like,
you know,
like,
oh,
I don't have any water in the house,
you know,
so I'm not like a conspiracy I,
or like a,
you know,
a hoarder or like a doomsday prepper or anything like that.
But like,
I just kinda like felt like I needed to know immediately.
So I've,
I've had CNN literally unloop for like 10 years after nine 11 saying like sort
of.
I assume you'd want to miss like,
eh.
Yeah,
I just wanted to know first I like to stop watching television.
Really?
I watch a lot of,
oh,
here we go.
I like how open Laden's looking in the camera to look right in the camera.
See what I'm doing.
I stopped watching.
I'm a big news junkie.
I've dialed it down way a lot in the last few years.
It's a pill,
it's shy,
it's fake manufactured.
It shines.
Like everything is like Tmz to cancel my cable.
And uh,
I enjoyed,
I enjoyed that.
Um,
but uh,
I watch a lot of,
uh,
a lot.
I watched a lot of rap videos on youtube if you'd like to see like the current
state of wraps.
So I like little pump and just wild out there and I like a juice swirled juice
world is hilarious.
I never
would have pegged you as a rap guy.
I like to stay on top of what's happening with the rap world.
A lot of beefs out there,
man.
Yeah,
Drake and Pusha T.
Yeah.
What'd you think of that beef?
That was pretty,
you know,
it was some interesting,
interesting.
Did you see Drake on the Bron?
Yeah,
that was interesting.
Talk to me about about the,
uh,
the level,
like the degree to which,
you know,
Kanye went to them to Wyoming be friended him and worked on the song together,
got all this information and then turn it,
you know,
Jujitsu that right against him.
That was really fucked up.
Yeah.
Not Nice.
Not Nice to our Canadian.
Uh,
that was a really fucked up man.
But you know,
looks like a,
he's a bit of a fucked up guy.
I think so.
Yeah.
I don't want to forget this because we've got a,
we have to uh,
wrap pretty stuff,
right?
I've got to go pick up that a older kid kid to pick up.
But look,
Tom Green is on the road.
There we go.
Yeah.
Look at that.
I'm so happy.
By the way,
the idea of a Tom Green show coming back.
I really think that happened.
I'm trying to make it,
I'm trying to make it happen so you can see him at the comedy connection.
Uh,
Providence,
Rhode Island.
Yeah.
Tom green.com.
Go to the tour page.
He's going to be a new Brunswick,
Levittown,
Boston Falls Church.
Burlington.
It's all their Buffalo,
Toronto,
Ontario and more.
Tom green.com.
Go to the tour page.
Can you go to Instagram on there?
Yeah.
Can I show you something I've been doing too on your Instagram?
Okay.
Yeah.
I just want to show you,
cause it's Kinda sometimes,
so what I've been doing lately and everyone follow me on Instagram.
Thank you Tom Green on Instagram.
Follow me.
Um,
I'm talking to the home viewers too.
I'd love it.
You guys following me too.
But,
uh,
I've been,
I've got a hard drive with all the old videos I did and uh,
I,
I've been going through and I've been re editing them,
not just taking clips but I've been reedited them into like condensed one minute
Instagram versions,
uh,
lately like this here.
Yeah.
And so it's kind of fun because they're almost like brand new videos cause
lost.
It's wearing a pair of white shorts.
Hopefully we'll just please follow this path by the girl sweat sweatpants.
I said these two on the PA Nancy,
some crazy.
Got Damn asking him to leave.
This is 1995 looked almost exactly like me doing it.
Actually it all he did was he picked this thing up.
I am allowed to leave cause I'm an a Donald cause you weren't invited.
We used to run,
the first place they get on a PA system was,
I personally invited it in the store.
First of all the supplies.
Okay,
well I'm going to leave him.
No,
I can charge you with trespassing.
Well No,
no because I'm leaving.
No,
he can.
Yeah,
no I didn't have a warrant and a few over here for a minute by the telephone.
Okay.
Yeah,
let's go up Michelle.
Okay.
Making these little one minute loops.
I love it.
Yup.
So go,
go follow my Instagram and uh,
at and leave a comment.
Tom Green.
Yep.
All right,
thanks.
I love it so much for having me.
On the show was great.
Wow.
Well Great.
I hope I didn't talk too much about myself.
No Man wants to hear you talking about yourself.
We'll leave you with this.
It's a come back again.
Yeah,
of course.
It goes crew,
uh,
greasy and I'm,
that's it.
Thank you Tom Green so much.
Thank you.
Oh,
is that all scoring?
Showing him?
I don't like taking pills,
but I have found something that works.
Australian dream,
breezy,
plain.
I don't like
spreading
the word.
I don't like taking pills,
but I have found something that works.
What is it?
Australian dream.